if I'm in project mode I might as well
clarify some things that are out there
that I really need to get off my chest
and it starts with this I respect you I
respect you I respect you so many of you
so many of you have different opinions
than I do
disagree with me comment leave your
three cents talked behind my back and I
want you to know so there is never any
confusion that I respect where you're
coming from you come from a different
place but different circumstances
different narratives and I will respect
it to the end I really welcome as long
as your points of view are coming from a
place of positivity added value debate
intellectual curiosity I respect you to
no end and even for the people that are
adding their two cents to the
conversation of my life
maybe I'll save my framework of not
leaving two cents in your life but if I
don't there you go even for the people
that have taken the time to have two
cents my life out of a place of weakness
and despair I need to get a short dose
of happiness and the spitting of their
negativity on my framework disguised as
constant constructive criticism or lack
of kool-aid drinking I respect it I
understand it and I deployed onion but
lethal amounts of gratitude for my
parents and my neighborhoods my homies
and my early rent inclined to crave the
foundation of my life
they respect that I respect and
respected speak your truth